guy bedos moi je n'ai pas beaucoup de
camarades de mon service militaire
puisque j'ai été réformé pour maladie
mentale mais
l'amitié moi je la connais bien sûr avec
avec mes amis j'en ai pas beaucoup mais
je les aime beaucoup et puis aussi
évidemment avec les gens les tous les
gens que je rencontre chaque soir parce
que je leur parle mais ce qui modère ce
qui vous aime parce qu'il vous voit dans
vos sketches oui j'en ai déjà là j'ai
des moments de sa vie avant moi je vous
connais peu et que je vous aime beaucoup
parce que j'ai vu ses sketches avec le
fait de mieux et j'ai versé une larme en
lisant votre livre là un certain moment
et certaines pages ou vous parlez de
sophie poux sur une route offert à
cesson chic et sur une route eh bien je
crois que vous avez sais pas si vous
avez des amis que vous connaissez mais
il ya beaucoup beaucoup vous connaissez
pas vous mais je le sens comme les
acteurs ont un mal fou pour être un
thématiques
c'est pourquoi parce que je sais d'une
dynamique chez moi ça m'est d'avis mais
vraiment ils ont dit que je n'aime pas
flatté je ne veux pas la démagogie je
n'aime pas la grimace de l'amitié je ne
veux pas le mensonge plus mais qui émeut
salle ici à part qui le dira qu'il
dirait sel gemme les sentiments exact
que l'on peux te dire qu'il devra
apprendre et je crois que monsieur bedos
train homme qui aime la solidarité et
celle des anonymes avec les anonymes
oui oui c'est à dire que moi mais mes
électeurs c'est le public vienne
quelques fois et puis et puis c'est vrai
qu'il ya une communion entre nous et
c'est très bon ça c'est très très
encourageant et bien merci